[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue c'est
désormais toute la planète qui surveille
un virus venu de chine
quatorze mille cas déclarés 304 morts
c'est le dernier bilan et une
propagation qui s'attend maintenant dans
24 pays du monde dont la france l' oms a
déclaré à l'urgence internationale
en france on se veut rassurant même si
air france a décidé de suspendre tous
ses vols vers la chine où la
contamination a commencé alors que
sait-on de ce virus
quels sont les risques comment éviter la
contamination la propagation quelles
peuvent être les conséquences
économiques avec nous sur ce plateau ce
matin pour en parler
le docteur sophie mailly bonjour vous
êtes médecin dans le service des
maladies infectieuses du chu de dijon
merci d'être avec nous un amant rien
vous êtes directeur de la santé publique
de la rs l' agence régionale de santé
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous et
puis enfin benoît de langalerie alors
vous vous êtes chef d'entreprise
bourguignon et vous travaillez
régulièrement avec la chine alors en
france le bilan a grimpé on a désormais
six malades alain morange me tombait à
vous aux 15 cas n'a été détecté en
bourgogne à ce jour mais ce que vous
êtes prêts à y faire face au cab ou
alors on travaille beaucoup en
anticipation en fait la politique du
ministère de la santé c'est d'éviter la
dissémination de du virus ça veut dire
que dès lors qu'on a la moindre
suspicion dès lors qu'une personne
revient de chine
elle doit on incite d'une part un pass
rendre chez son médecin traitant
elle pas de se rendre aux urgences elle
téléphoné au centre 15 donc c'est le
premier message dont il ya tout un
travail d'anticipation qui est réalisé
avec les deux centres hospitaliers
universitaires de dijon et besançon qui
sont habilités à prendre en charge les
cas mais également arrêté médecins
libéraux est ce qu'on est prêt oui on
est prêt le mal a dit le service des
maladies infectieuses et le service où
vous travaillez aujourd'hui si on a un
cas qui se présentent en bourgogne
c'est là bas qu'on va diriger le patient
tout à fait donc on travaille en
coopération avec ars pour classer le cas
initialement suspect comme possible
isoler le patient en évitant comme on
l'a rappelé le service des eaux le
service des urgences et ensuite faire
les prélèvements adapté pour confirmer
ou pas le cas vous avez cette nuit on a
daily qu'on peut mettre en effet des
chambres qu'on peut maintenant
dépression ce qui permet à 10,2 d'éviter
la propagation du virus de façon
nosocomiales dans l'hôpital c'est
deschamps qui sont équipés de deux sas
donc on peut s'habiller mater masque
pour aller voir daniel le malade 1 cette
lie au chu de dijon aujourd'hui si un
casse présent si on en a 8 10 22 cas
comment ça se passe j'en à six autres à
besançon donc on travaille pour mais
franche comté s'est déjà treize lits et
au delà de ça on travaille également en
anticipation à identifier d'autres
établissements qui pourraient prendre en
compte prendre en charge les patients
qui pourraient se présenter
on en est très loin puisqu'on ya zéro
donc la montée en charge et se fera
progressivement on voit bien que
l'épidémie en france
limiter très limité le virus ne circule
pas aller parmi les six cas on a cinq
cas de personnes qui étaient venues de
chine
le dernier cas est un médecin qui était
contaminée par une chinoise qui a
déclaré la maladie à son retour en chine
la ministre de la santé agnès buzyn
disait ya quelques jours faut pas
paniquer on agit mais faut pas paniquer
puis dans le même temps on l'a vu dans
les journaux et dans les médias ces
derniers jours on rapatrie on confine
ont fermé frontières alors est-ce que
c'est grave ou pas ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est contagieux
probablement beaucoup plus contagieux
que le strass la gravité semble moindre
ensuite c'est un nouveau virus il ya
plusieurs courants d'un virus qui sont
connus à ce jour
il y en avait six jusqu'à présent
tondeuse responsable de symptômes graves
et ce troisième coronavirus dont la
gravité semble quand même moindre par
rapport au tracé aux moeurs crevé mais
il faut rester vigilant qui dit
vigilance dit papa nick on est
déclenché un système d' alerte de
vigilance benoît de langalerie vous
m'aviez dit quand on préparé cette
émission la chine c'est ma deuxième
maison du travail est régulièrement
chiffres vous y étiez d'ailleurs début
janvier
quelle est l'ambiance sur place que
comme on vit la communauté française
c'est chaud c'est ce qu'elle vit dans la
peur oui alors début janvier quand j
étais les choses n'étaient pas encore
déclaré donc j'ai pas vécu directement
sur place qui s'est passé par contre
j'ai les employés sur place donc j'ai
des retours journalier on suit de très
près l'évolution
les retours que j'ai aujourd'hui c'est
que la mise en place par le gouvernement
a été fait de manière
vraiment forte et permet aujourd'hui de
rassurer l'ensemble de la population
les gens restent chez eux toutes les
personnes qui sont pas dans la province
du roubaix sont quand même dans
l'ensemble des personnes qui attendent
en fait et qui au bout du compte sont en
famille et aucun véhicule qui est
différent entre les français qui sont en
chine et le chinois alors oui on va dire
que parfois le retour que je peux avoir
aujourd'hui en appelant quelques amis
sur place français c'est que les
français eux sont plus dans la tente de
savoir ce qui va se passer par la suite
à savoir s'ils rentrent chez eux à
savoir si les raids sur place alors que
les chinois sont plus à l'écouté
gouvernement local est prêt à repartir
au travail ou de 10 février
c'est pour les provinces qui ne sont pas
dans le groupe b comment la population
est informée sur place alors elle est
informée de différentes manières
beaucoup de réseaux sociaux oui chat
aujourd'hui et sûrement le lire et
social le plus puissant au monde et
c'est vrai que même moi aujourd'hui avec
les entrepreneurs français en chine
on entend des groupes de plus de 100 150
entrepreneurs français sur wii chat donc
on se tient au courant
qu'est ce qu'on vous dit alors on se dit
bastien est ce que tel ou tel groupe
français va rapatrier ses employés ou
pain et puis quand je lisais les
réponses au corps hier soir des grands
groupes en plaçant en chine le
rapatriement n'est pas une option pour
le moment donc c'est que la crise est
quand même bien géré et s'il y a besoin
le lancement seront de toute façon donc
c'est que pour l'instant tant qu'on
n'est pas dans le roubaix donc on n'est
pas dans une zone de cris de crise
il suffit de rester chez soi et
d'attendre que ça passe je pense que
c'est la meilleure solution pour moi que
ça se développe aujourd'hui on voit
beaucoup de l'image avec des masques
sophie mais il aimait ça marche ou pas
les masques ça marche ça fait partie des
mesures de prévention incontournable
dans une épidémie dont le la
transmission se fait par voie
respiratoire ainsi que lavage des mains
comment au combat ce virus comment on
traite les malades alain
alors comme on traite les malades on n'a
pas de traitement spécifique n'est pas
de vaccin il n'y aura pas de vaccins
avant plus d'un plugin années 2000 21 21
parce que c'est
contrairement à la grippe la grippe on
connaît le mode de fabrication d'un
vaccin grippe n'existe pas sur le marché
de deux vaccins contre le corona virus
en général donc il faut développer un
axe 1 faire des essais cliniques parce
qu'il doit être à la fois efficace et
sûr et après il va falloir le produire
on est sur des productions de centaines
de millions de doses maintenant est ce
qu'il ya un intérêt également à produire
un vaccin tout dépendra un peu des
données épidémiologiques qu'on va avoir
il s'adressera probablement si on va
dans cette dans cette dynamique
probablement pas à l'ensemble de la
population n'est plus tôt on voit les
premières on a un premier retour là des
quelques publications qui pourrait
sortir on voit que l'âge médian il est
aux alentours de 59 ans on voit que ça
touche plutôt les personnes qui ont des
comorbidités donc on n'est pas sûr de la
population générale en bonne santé c'est
plutôt des personnes fragiles les
premières données que l'on a faut pas
oublier que ce virus il était inconnu il
ya encore un mois
il a été des premières identifications
remonte au 9 janvier l'institut pasteur
vient d'annoncer qu'il avait fait de
séquençage donc c'est excessivement
court et les données que l'on apporte
sur quelques centaines de patients donc
il faut attendre un peu pour avoir
davantage de données pour savoir
exactement quelle est un an je
souhaitais qu'elle est là la
contamination possible avec ce virus est
également le type de pathologie qui
aimerait associer la population qui va
être plutôt la cible de ce vide de ce
virus par donc poser la question comme
ça mais on meurt de quoi avec ce virus
c'est comme une grecque
c'est comme une grippe sur les
complications donc ça va être une
infection respiratoire basse donc une
harmonie qui peut se compliquer en
particulier avec des surinfections comme
on peut le voir dans la grippe est en
fonction du terrain de fragilité sous
jacent il peut y avoir d'autres
complications qui se surajoutent à ça
quand on fait votre métier c'est quoi
qu'on redoute c'est quoi le scénario
scénario noir c'est d'avoir une
situation qui nous échappe
c'est à dire plus être en capacité de
répondre donc pour ça qu'on traque on
travaille beaucoup en anticipation on
est déjà à réfléchir à qu'est ce qui
peut se passer si on est à plus de 15
cas que vous disiez au niveau de la
région
ça veut dire qu'il faut aussi réfléchir
avec les médecins libéraux
parce que aujourd'hui on est sur un
hospital au centrisme de la prise en
charge
il faudra le ministère commence à vous
demander de réfléchir ou de prise en
charge ambulatoire pour les cas mon
grave parce qu'on voit bien dans les six
cas en fait qu ont été hospitalisés en
france il ya quand même quatre cas non
graves
il reste hospitalisé ton qu'ils ont le
virus mais on n'a pas de
systématiquement des formes sévères faut
beaucoup relativiser on a effectivement
deux personnes qui sont en soins
intensifs
pour le reste et de passion qui vont
bien on redoute pour ma part
pratico-pratique de médecins
hospitaliers
on redoute le patient qui arrive
directement service des urgences sans
avoir prévenu le centre 15 en aval et où
là forcément il peut y avoir une
exposition de d'autres patients de
personnel soignant et où forcément ça
complique
ça complique les choses donc c'est tout
le travail en effet d'anticipation qui
est fait d'informations qui est très
très important beaucoup de prévention
beaucoup de précautions pour être un
petit peu au dessus du du danger c'est
ça l'idée aujourd'hui si cela l'idée
bien informé la population est restée
sur la politique et la note c'est éviter
la dissémination du virus
aujourd'hui on est confronté à cette
épidémie de en chine depuis un mois veut
dire que quand même ce qui était mis en
place aujourd'hui fonctionne puisque on
a que six cas et on voit bien les six
cas ils ont été un petit peu perlé et on
n'a pas d'autre cas depuis lors jamais
que deux ou trois jours mais quand on
voit la vitesse de propagation des cas
confirmé en chine
faut pas oublier que 99 9% des cas que
l'on retrouve effectivement les 24 pays
ses 99 9% en chine on a six cas en
france donc aux philippines depuis ce
matin mort qui est un chinois
manifestement qui s'est rendu aux
philippines c'est pas une personne qui
était contaminé sur le territoire de
notre langue
les conséquences sur votre métier vous
là vous êtes en stand by vous partez
plus travailler en chine comment ça se
passe pour vous oui alors j'avais prévu
un voyage du 10 au 16 février qu'on a
par précaution annulé donc on va
travailler par vidéoconférence le temps
que que les choses avancent d'après mes
équipes ce matin on a un retour de 80 %
des ouvriers le dise pour leur prise le
10 sachant qu'ils travaillent du travail
sachant que nos activités sont basées
dans le sud de la chine donc assez loin
du roubaix là où se trouve une grosse
partie l'industrie voilà dans mon
secteur
je pense que dans l'ensemble on peut
dire que c'est difficile c'est un peu
tôt pour savoir exactement ce qui est ce
que ça va engendrer
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête du
chef d'entreprise que vous êtes là
depuis plusieurs semaines parce qu'en
plus vous êtes concernés à plusieurs
styles vous avez vécu 15 ans en chine
votre femme et chinoises et vous
travaillez avec la chine heureusement ça
fait déjà plusieurs années qu'on a une
stratégie aussi de développement en
europe
donc on ne produit pas qu'en chine et
mais on a des clients qui vendent des
produits en chine et qui ont besoin
qu'on reste sur place pour les
accompagner des entreprises on sait ce
qu'ils ont besoin de vente sur cette
partie du globe
donc là on se rapproche d'eux cette
partie là aujourd'hui ça va être un
travail de précaution auprès de tous les
employés en permanence pour savoir
quelles vont être les retours à la suite
du 10 février
comment assurer les productions comment
assurer les livraisons puissent il faut
reporter on ya une inquiétude
aujourd'hui du monde des affaires
pas encore je pense pas je pense qu'il
ya une de toute façon une inquiétude par
principe on voit la bourse
aujourd'hui qui fait quelques vagues
automatiquement 20 % de l'économie
mondiale est en chine aujourd'hui donc
automatiquement
on ressent mais je pense que après le 10
février on aura une réponse peut-être
plus précises sur ce sur ces choses là
je pense que d'après des employés
chinois
j'ai l'impression que l ils ont
l'impression que le pic va être atteints
aux autres autour du 10 février qu'il de
l'épidémie
voilà donc jusque là c'est difficile de
se prononcer est ce que les mesures de
confinement vous ça vous fait craindre
des pertes économiques
encore une fois c'est un peu tôt pour le
dire c'est un peu tôt pour le dire parce
que la réactivité chinoise est quand
même impressionnante
donc une fois qu'ils sont remis au
travail c'est vrai que ça peut aller
vite et la pente peut être vite remonter
mais automatiquement oui il y aura une
petite perte économique mais je pense
pas qu'aujourd'hui on aidé des clients
qu'ils aient peur de 2 commandés par
exemple en chine
parce que les choses sont vraiment pris
en charge correctement par le
gouvernement et on a ce feedback
d'ailleurs on le voit dans les médias
aujourd'hui les chaussons sont quand
même pris en charge correctement et
voilà à la mort c'est une question on me
disait je rebondis sur les propos de
benoît c'est une question qu'on me pose
souvent est ce qu'il ya un risque de
contamination quand on commande des
objets en chine alors qu'une question
effectivement qui est arrivé très tôt je
crois que le deuxième jour on a eu une
alerte on avait déjà la question qui
était arrivé par les centres postaux
à ce jour il n'y a jamais eu de
contamination démontrer pas lors des
épisodes de strass mercy corps n'a
jamais eu le moindre contamination par
un paquet on peut commander chinois on
peut manger chinois aussi c'est vraiment
du chinois wuxi chine on a des données
quand même pour dire que le virus
persiste et deux à trois heures sur une
surface inerte
donc c'est des données tout à fait
rassuré dire toi que le virus passe il
ya toujours le problème dans ces
infections la de manu portet une
infection de toucher une surface
contaminée d'aller en mettre ailleurs et
ça on sait que la durée de vie du virus
sur des surfaces inerte une table une
poignée de porte ça sera deux à trois
heures alors on sait on sait aussi
aujourd'hui que que dijon est la
deuxième ville de france la plus visitée
par les touristes chinois après paris
est-ce que du coup de votre côté avoue
le risque est plus important pour la
bourgogne le risque est-il le plus
important ce stade de toute façon il n'y
a pas de mesures de confinement il ya il
ya des messages qui sont passés si vous
quelqu'un qui vient de chine pendant les
quatorze jours on le demande de
surveiller si la température et s'il ya
des signes cliniques de toux ou de
grande fatigue s'il a passé synalia il
n'y a pas de problème on n'est pas du
tout sur une notion de conflits nés tout
le monde et je dirais même si jamais au
cas où même on a un cas confirmé
derrière on va essayer de on va
rechercher tous les cas contactez son
appel n'est qu'un contact c'est à dire
les personnes qui auraient été dans un
contact rapproché corps et partager une
chambre ou corée était en face à face
lorsque la personne est terminée et on
va on va
vérifiez auprès de ses contacts derrière
que pendant 14 jours il ne devine et
n'ont pas de symptômes qui pourraient
faire penser qu' ils ont été contaminées
est ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui aux
touristes qui rentre justement comment
ça se passe et qui qui qui s'occupe de
ça alors il ya la formation qui est
faite aux voyageurs dans les hôpitaux ça
c'est dans le cadre de tout ce qui était
mise en place ce qu'on appelle le
règlement sanitaire international cd
affiches qui sont qui sont qui sont
transmis mais je crois qu'il ya des
messages d'information qui passe aussi
dans les avions avant l'atterrissage
c'est suffisant c'est suffisant sait
déjà c'est déjà beaucoup
je pense que les gens sont informés en
voyageant je pense que le grand public
en france aussi est informé donc ensuite
il ya le téléphone qui est disponible
aussi pour des questions et on est
sollicité au régulièrement s'il reste
des questions
pour répondre à ces interrogations
il ya effectivement un numéro vert on va
leur donner c'est le 0 800 300 00 un
numéro gratuit un numéro vert accessible
à tous alors pour toutes les questions
sauf il m'a dit qu'ils sont non médical
oui les questions médicales c'est on
revient au démarrage c'est le centre
pivot le centre 15 donc on appelle le 15
quand on revient de chic et qu'on a des
symptômes ou qu'on a des questions
médicales ou alors on se met en rapport
avec son médecin traitant si on a des
questions médicales d'entre général
effectivement le numéro vert qui était
mis en place ce week-end ne répond qu'à
des questions non médical à savoir
également qu'il ya des foires aux
questions sur les sites du ministère de
la santé de l'agencé nationale de santé
publique qui s'appelle la santé publique
france donc on retrouve des foires aux
questions qui sont mises à jour très
régulièrement et qui permettent de
répondre à beaucoup de questions
la question des colis la question d'un
nourriture
toutes ces questions sont abordées et au
moins on a quand même des sites
officiels qui apporte des réponses qui
sont des réponses scientifiques
éprouvées ce qu'on voit aussi deux le
nombre de faits que news qui circule
beaucoup plus vite que lui et russe je
me voyais sur les réseaux sociaux cette
inquiétude ou la santé vont vous
l'apercevez depuis quelques jours on
aperçoit non une veille
sur le sur les réseaux sociaux pour voir
ce qui se passe notamment au niveau de
la région qui nous intéresse c'est
éventuellement on a vu sur les réseaux
sociaux des techno sur le fait qu'il y
avait des cadres que renault virus qui
appelle à dijon donc démenti on a
démenti mais oui c'est inquiétant
c'est inquiétant mais c'est difficile à
maîtriser d'où l'intérêt d'avoir ces
dispositifs de official qui permettent
de répondre aux inquiétudes légitimes de
la population
benoît de langalerie voix très posée les
chinoises vous avez des enfants qui ont
la nationalité aussi est ce que vous
avez senti vous aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux ces messages qu'on voit c'est
peut-être cette appréhension par rapport
à la communauté chinoise
alors je pense qu'il ya deux choses il
ya l'appréhension des français en france
par rapport aux chinois quand on va dans
un restaurant c'est vrai qu'on est à
garder un petit peu différemment à dijon
quand on arrive avec une chinoise et un
enfant ça vous arrive et ça oui oui oui
on a senti qu'il y avait des regards
parce que les gens en parlent les gens
peut-être en rigole aussi enfin il ya
vraiment c'est un sujet donc voilà en
vouloir de quelque part de d'en parler
mais c'est vrai qu'on ressent et ma
femme l'a ressenti oui mon fils aussi à
l'école qu'est ce qu'on lui a dit à
l'école avec lui vous avez les enfants 8
ans 9 ans peuvent être dures entre eux
donc c'est pas c'est pas des choses très
on lui a simplement dit voilà attention
le petit chinois ton papa était en chine
tu as infectés donc bon c'est pas
toujours évident mais voilà il fait ça a
été pris en très bien par les
professeurs et et on a pu discuter avec
eux et ils ont expliqué aux autres
élèves qui allaient il avait aucun souci
est alors l'un des épisodes précédents
c'était le sras syndrome respiratoire
aigu sévère c'était en 2003 à 800 voire
benoît langalerie vous vous étiez en
chine à cette époque dans ses dires vous
envie d'apprendre mais j'ai voyagé
pendant le strass en train je me
souviens encore de pékin à shine
je vais encore des poules dans le train
à cette époque là c'était géré d'une
manière complètement différente
déjà le gouvernement n'était pas le même
le la gestion de
de la crise ne pouvait pas être fait la
même manière à temps et qui a pas de
réseaux sociaux comme il ya aujourd'hui
à l'époque elle avait été pointé du
doigt justement on disait qu'il y avait
peu de communication est ce que ça a
changé aujourd'hui c'est un discours de
transparence d'après aujourd'hui la
chine fait évoluer à une vitesse folle
dans plein de secteurs dont si la
gestion de crise et c'est clair
qu'aujourd'hui je tire mon chapeau bas à
la façon dont ces géré par ce que
j'appelle mes amis français sur place
mais où on mes amis chinois
tout le monde est assez très au courant
de ce qui se passe
les réseaux sociaux et les systèmes qui
sont mis en place par le gouvernement
pour les étrangers nous explique quelles
sont les démarches à faire
traduit en français donc de là à ce que
le gouvernement français un jour
traduisent des choses en chinois pour
les ressortissants chinois en france
je pense qu'il se passera petit moment
danser les choses sont prises à une
vitesse folle avec des avec avec des
moyens impressionnants donc oui c'est
très différent de la gestion du stress
en 2003 sa fille marie en 2003 le strass
était le problème c'était ça c'était le
manque de transparence et de
communication départ ya eu un retard à
l'allumage c'est certain la c'est vrai
qu'on voit que très vite c'était un
nouveau virus donc déjà d'un point de
vue technique fallait trouver la
technique d'identification quoi la
technique on l'avait mais fallait avoir
le séquençage et avoir de l'outil
diagnostic ça ça a été très rapidement
mis en place donc ça c'est très bien
puisqu'on a pu identifier
l'agent infectieux et je pense qu'on a
tiré des grandes conséquences de cette
épidémie là puisqu'il ya beaucoup de cas
de transmission à l'hôpital nosocomiales
deux patients un patient et maintenant
on sait voilà qu'il faut vraiment gérer
en amont pour éviter cette dissémination
et je pense c'était une des plus grandes
leçons qui a été tirée de de cette
épidémie tient à la mort un ace que du
point de vue du matériel et des
procédures les choses ont changé depuis
le strass sur le matériel pape a pas
énormément puisque on est toujours sur
des précautions
dis parce que la vache démarre le lavage
des mains on n'en parle pas beaucoup
mais c'est quelque chose de fondamental
dans la lutte contre la dissémination le
premier message qu'ont passé lavez vous
les mains utiliser des mouchoirs
jetables et éternuer dans le coude et si
vous êtes malade porte un masque
donc on a beaucoup le message passe on
voit le il ya un gros travail qui a été
fait dans les services hospitaliers avec
des équipes d'hygiène
on a des djihadistes qu'on goûte
beaucoup travaillé sur ces procédures là
donc on a beaucoup évolué parce que
également il ya une succession on parle
du strass et une mère ce qu il ya eu et
bola il y avait la charge ya eu achats
et nal quand même donc il ya une une
récurrence des phénomènes qui fait que
c'est une sorte de répétition on
s'améliore à chaque fois on fait des
retours techno dans les hôpitaux en
france depuis
depuis 20 ans on s'entraîne parce que on
est en alerte et un peu permanente en
effet je pense que on est tous le monde
sait pas on était encore en alerte sur
on est encore en alerte sur le maire ce
cauvin qui c'est quoi un autre
coronavirus et donc on est en alerte
permanente sur des gens qui reviennent
de pays du moyen-orient avec des
symptômes respiratoires une maladie
beaucoup moins contagieuse mais beaucoup
plus mortel ça c'est certain
donc on est en alerte depuis plusieurs
années maintenant sur ces infections
respiratoires dont mr sco b dont nouveau
courant d'un virus et caetera et donc le
système est quand même éprouver les
mesures ont pas grandement changé c'est
surtout l'organisation en amont qui est
voilà paris notamment affiné basse et
c'est toujours centraliser les choses
éviter l'arrivée direct des patients aux
urgences ou voilà en travail par
informer les gens et en effet informé
les autres hôpitaux pour que le malade
soit pris directement en charge s'il est
classé comme un cas possible directement
dans le service alors une autre question
qu'on a beaucoup entendu ces derniers
jours c'est un virus qui vient encore de
chine comme on explique ça pourquoi ce
qui vient de chine bat suez vient de
chine et volaille vient du congo
et le h1n1 ils venaient du mexique donc
le strass de chine
donc gros navires us on sait qu'il ya
quand même un réservoir animal
probablement sheila chez la chauve
souris avec une contamination
probablement d'un autre d'un autre
mammifère donc il y avait là si bêtes
qui avaient été incriminés pour pour le
strass avec monde et des marchés qui
sont des marchés d'animaux etc
on pourrait peut-être nous parle et où
il ya probablement une exposition entre
animal et humain qui fait qu'il ya
l'émergence de ce nouveau virus
peut-être plus dans cette région da est
en effet le sras c'était aussi
originaire de chine et on a pu lutter
contre l'épidémie en strass en voilà une
fois qu'on a su qu'un col réservoir
était chez lâcher la civette
une dernière question à tous que quelles
sont les recommandations aujourd'hui
elle pour nous tous en population
générale
il n'y a pas d'inquiétude du tout et
même pas de recommandations si ce n'est
que des recommandations pour oublier que
la grippe est là qu on est en phase
épidémique de la grippe c'est entre cinq
et dix mille morts par an en france donc
le lavage des mains d'éternuements que
tousser dans son coude et porter un
masque quand on est malade et en ce qui
nous concerne pour les si vous revenez
de chine vous appeler le centre 15
ça fait mal et un dernier mot pareil et
pour dire qu'il ya aussi des documents
qui sont traduits en chinois qui sont
disponibles des affiches et cetera
commun dans un centre hospitalier avec
une traduction chinoise qui sont tout à
fait adaptées vous voulez vous est
plutôt rassurant c'est ça qu'on peut
dire aujourd'hui on est rassuré
oui pourquoi on est rassurant parce que
le système le système et et prouver
qu'on a quand même des rassurante sur
une mortalité qui est pas très élevé eh
bien merci à tous les trois vous êtes
venu sur ce plateau pour débattre de
cette question et du coronavirus on va
peut-être redonner un numéro vert à
votre disposition
huit cents 300 0 0 donc un numéro
gratuit accessible à tous tous les jours
pour toutes les questions les questions
nous médicale sur le corona à virus
dimension politique continue dans un
instant francis letellier reçoit
ségolène royal la semaine prochaine
c'est jean christophe gallais dit que
vous retrouverez ici même sur ce plateau
et puis vous restez avec nous parce que
tout de suite c'est l'information avec
emmanuel par sono merci très belle
journée à vous
[Musique]